two players remained Wesley so and nihal
sarin after six months of play hundreds
of qualification tournaments and a
64-player knockout with the best players
in the world so and Sauron had tramped
against all opposition and now played
for the title of global chess champion
and the 200 000 first prize in this
million dollar event
so kicked things off with white setting
the tone with an amazing game maybe his
best game of the event Nihao selected
the solid Petrov defense and the opening
position was symmetrical and only very
slightly better for white but so showed
Superior command of the resulting
position wow I do not like that at what
is the long-term plan here he's starting
to slide off the ledge a little bit here
right now what exactly is wrong here
22a4 was a sophisticated move that
impressed the commentators and oddly
prepared swinging the Knight to H4 and
on to F5 with a powerful knight and
h-pond and kingside pressure developing
so let me Hal devour his pawns on the
queen side but his attack was
overwhelming so close things out with 30
Knight G6 and 32 Rook takes E7 both
moves that received the brilliant
annotation and shortly forced
resignation in a game that's so played
with an accuracy of 90
7.9 according to game review
[Music]
game 2 was a tone Setter as so got a
great position with black and could have
pressed but he accepted nihao's proffer
draw with a one game lead so would not
be opposed to splitting a point yeah I
could totally see him squeezing out a
win in this kind of end game like this
type of position is a nightmare to have
against Wesley okay Rook dc1 has been
played and accompanied with a dropper
which Wesley has accepted
wow that's an interesting decision
Fabby what do you make of that I was not
expecting that that totally had a left
deal maybe the time situation played a
role yeah but in that case why not play
night before because there you're just a
bit better uh but okay draw overall good
result for Wesley I mean we can discuss
whether or not he should have played on
a little bit longer I think we see like
a look of disappointment and maybe that
means that he was expecting to have more
of an advantage and then he had to
settle for uh you know thinking that
he's not actually that much better and
he just goes for a draw uh
I don't know if he's disappointed
overall with this result or if he's
happy to have made a very stable draw
with black where he was never in danger
he's sitting there and still analyzing
right so he's still looking at the
looking at the board and going could I
have played a little bit more
ambitiously in game three the most
dramatic game of the match so
temporarily reversed his safe course and
played a speculative exchange sacrifice
with 16 Rook takes H5 yeah right here he
just gave up that Rook on age that's
something Danny would do honestly yo are
you coaching him okay it does feel a
little unnecessary now that we talk
about it um maybe uh he remembered the
uh exchange sacrifice Hikaru made and
thinks that there's some compensation
there but no this doesn't look on this
doesn't look necessary for why why did
he do that why not just G4 even instead
of H5 to begin with Nihao responded
excellently and even outplayed so
reaching a nearly winning position but
so kept posing practical problems with
his pair of Bishops and he finally
induced a first error from Nihao in 30
Rook to G6 which conceded the advantage
Rook G6 allowing Queen h8 whilst he
plays that quickly and if King goes to
E7 I'm already looking at Bishop takes
E5 you're getting after that King this
bishop can come to D3 at some point to
attack The Rook I feel like you know
really might be more likely to lose this
game than to win it after more strong
defense Nihao cracked in huge time
pressure with 39 King to D5 which
allowed forced mate so closed out
perfectly and showed his emotions with a
powerful hand clap what was that move oh
my God I think Neo's playing for a win
but he's really playing for a loss here
and Wesley down to 15 seconds himself he
was Bishop F5 he cuts this king off B4
and Bishop C5 would be Checkmate but now
B4 on passant don't forget about that
rule so it's Queen H6 oh my gosh Queen
D2 is Checkmate C4 you're not escaping
no you're not Queen D3 He just got
himself checkmated
it's me oh my God and C4 C4 came before
Queen c3's Checkmate King guy two queen
a3's Checkmate it's game over it's just
Checkmate and Wesley so finds it and he
goes up two points in his final he
collaps his hand you see the smile on
his face Wesley so in staring down
defeat he escapes not just with a half
point with a full point and he now is in
charge here in the championship match in
the fourth and final game of day one
Nihao struggled to gain an edge and the
game was soon drawn in the interview
afterwards so said the quiet part out
loud with a two-game lead his best
strategy on day two was to play solidly
and make draws
yeah the score one and a half out of
four uh
yeah try to make many drops
nihal opened day two with a good effort
with the black pieces he got play and
even got an advantage but so was just
too solid and he liquidated the pressure
confidently in the end game famously the
bishop and the H Pawn do not win because
the bishop is not on the right colored
square that we say if it was a light
squared Bishop of course that would win
but yeah we just see a complete trade
and King against King fighting to the
bear Kings on a draw and a draw is in
the books that is good news for Wesley
so as he tries to make fetch happen and
fetch 200 000 first place prize we see
him walking off the board the computer
there and now he's gonna go to the
player area where he is going to take a
deep breath as he leads now three and a
half to one now Bobby then Nihao
returned to a fond memory in game six as
he played the rare three Bishop to F4
that he had used to win a brilliancy
against anishkiri in their match are we
gonna get the move three Knight C3 no
we're gonna get a repeat of the move he
played against Niche Bishop f4 on the
board do you think Wesley prepared for
that yeah he did I mean they're
repeating it and they're repeating oh
look how weirdly he took with the queen
that was a statement that was a
statement move and uh if we just I'm
just gonna very very quickly show up to
the move Knight Knight D2 this is the
move that has been played many many
times that's not on the board right now
the queen took and then went straight
back and Wesley's like thanks man I'm up
upon after eight moves so had naturally
reviewed that game closely and he came
prepared he claimed an advantage with
black still Nihao could be happy that
the position was complex with attacking
prospects and Anything could happen
exactly what he needed Fabiano caruana
predicted that chaos was likely and
Nihao should find some winning chances
as the game developed even though it's a
trade of pieces there are still a lot of
pieces on the board and attacking
potential and I'll make a slight
prediction not on the result of the game
but I feel like at some point in this
game Niha will get winning chances
whether that means some sort of
advantage or even like a winning
Advantage I think that will happen
because it feels like a position
especially low on time where it's easy
to lose control Carolina's prediction
seemed sound but so shut down every
attempt by nihal defending with Deft
King dodging Maneuvers including 24 King
G7 26 King h8 and then 29 King G8 after
shows accurate 30 Pawn to G5 with his
chances evaporating mihao made a final
Bluff with 31 H6 oh my God Levy at that
point H6 played replacing the
nobody can just take it in the Knight
defense G7 and you can't take the Knight
because the Rook takes on D1 with check
G takes F4 wins the game for Wesley yep
all he takes the four is over G takes
have four king slides over and that's it
there's no Queen G7 it's a blunder of a
bishop or I don't know maybe just a
failed sacrifice but this we might be
looking at the final moves of the
chess.com Global Championship right here
there we go nihal with the final Bluff
Wesley does not buy it g takes F4 and
the last gasps Forney house on you can
just see it on Wesley's face he knows it
nihal knows it the game is over Wesley
breathes a sigh of relief if he as he's
now just up a bishop he's not about
anymore there was just one flaw so
focused in and he took the second
sacrificed Bishop on F4 clinching the
game and forcing resignation in 10 more
moves
and that's it that's it ladies and
gentlemen
that's time so Wesley so is our champion
of the 2022 chess.com Global
Championship here in Toronto all smiles
as Wesley takes the first cgc title and
the 200
000 first prize Levy what a moment what
a moment indeed Wesley so we see they're
holding the 24 Karat 50-pound trophy
that may or may not be accurate massive
congratulations to him he has been
lights out the past two matches I don't
know if anybody has ever deserved a
victory more than Wesley deserves the
cgc title let's review our final score
he wins with a dominant score of four
and a half one and a half it was
basically a wire to wire Victory Levy
Wesley so is the first ever chess.com
Global chess champion and he showed his
class and gratitude in a speech replete
with thanks and joy I'd like to first
thank my mother and my family they did a
great job supporting me I'd like to
thank chess.com and the sponsors for
hosting this wonderful event the players
are treated here like kings basically
like monarch this is the best tournament
that I've ever
played in I I think I can say that
honestly and I'm very grateful for the
people that made this happen like my
friend Danny wrench also like a fake
shout out to my neighbors in Minnesota
and brynmore
they watch my game uh yesterday like
they spent the entire weekend watching
my games
did a fantastic job it's one of the best
broadcasts that people ever seen so's
Journey included victories over lazovic
Evancho Zhang and draken Hikaru Nakamura
and finally Nihao Sauron an amazing
string of triumphs from a true champion
[Music]
[Applause]